[Applaudissements]
la liste n'est pas encore constitué mais
daniel chomet est prêt dit-il à faire
d'une douille on dort une ville et notre
plan c'est nous rappelleront peut-être
ceux de 2014 où le candidat malheureux
avait vu sa liste invalidée au dernier
moment pour non conformité
aujourd'hui le paysage a changé un
adversaire d'hier est devenu allié et il
s'en explique aisément
j'ai considéré que l'urgence c'était de
donner congé à la majorité sortante le
plus vite possible
mille type lier les candidatures alors
que nous partageons avec dany chômé
temps le constat que les moyens à mettre
en oeuvre pour remédier et bien pour une
fois il convenait d'être intelligent
utile et assurer la victoire ce qui nous
unit ce sont les valeurs de démocratie
de justice et l'ambition autour d'un
projet cher ville durable avec des
piliers essentiels pour porter des
réponses concrètes au bien être des
hommes à l'attractivité du territoire
mais furent aussi de chercheurs une
ville stratégique où il fait bon vivre
schoelcher dynamique et solidaire
affiche aujourd'hui le soutien officiel
du parti républicain martiniquais mais
daniel chomet anciens du ppm peut
surtout compter sur l'appui du rdr qui
participera à sa liste avec en
martinique
nos critiques ont noué rdm beaucoup des
styles de deux d'exercice de pouvoir
solitaire et est un petit peu trop trop
absolue
sans participation véritable des
composantes d'une majorité sans
participation suffisante des citoyens là
notre accord c'est surtout sur cette
base d'une démocratie vraiment
participative d'une d'une majorité dans
toutes les composantes vont pouvoir
s'exprimer au moins trois listes se
présentent cette année contre le maire
sortant h el cheikh pour tous un même
défi changer le scénario de 2014 et
permettre un second tour de changer la
donne à schoelcher
[Applaudissements]